hey how's it going today we're unboxing
this new headset i did a quick google
to get some information direct pairing
to console exceptional
sound they're light and flexible
best-in-class
audio performance low latency
for chat which is also very important
comfortable intuitive design
it also says it's tailored to you to me
i think that we just need to open it
congrats on being one of the first
people to receive the all-new xbox
wireless headset which delivers it
this is all the stuff i just said voice
isolation helps pick up
your voice and not the background noise
auto mute i
love that play wirelessly across
multiple devices including xbox series x
s 1 windows 10 connect to your mobile
device for bluetooth for on-the-go music
where am i going i go to my fridge i go
to my couch
a little headset this looks nice
oh oh this is custom
this is custom look it's got my little
name on it
oh look at you look at you
i'm glad that they put the left and
right because
we all know i have problems with that
this is ig5 time reporting for duty
is anybody there hello look at this nice
little stand
like this looks incredible whoa
it just turned on these are little dials
so there's something happening in my
head right now i think it's
looking for my xbox it's downstairs i'll
take you downstairs
in a second just can you hold on a
second so it looks like on this side we
have a volume dial so this will adjust
your overall volume
we've got usbc right here for charging
we've got our mic button right here
it looks like this side here will be
your mix between
game and voice chat so that's cool that
all of this
is basically accessible right here on
your headset they're actually very
comfortable too
like i'm comfy i'm cozy start the game
start the game
here we go okay
am i yelling i'm not sure it's so loud
like in my head
can you hear me i mean i can you can't i
can hear
a lot oh saint patrick's stockpile
free for all is my favorite game mode
let's show these
noobs what's up can anybody hear me can
anybody hear me talking do you want to
be my friend
you want to fight so there's a little
light here and this will let you know if
your mic is on or off and there's a
little mic switch button
right there on the bottom oh you're my
friend you're my friend
you're my friend hello
can anybody hear me please confirm
confirm or deny
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh look at this
pot of gold freaking get it dude
get the get the gold oh oh oh
that's that's my body
on the floor they let it hit yo stupid
idiot
i just spit all over myself
i'm a disgusting hog so i missed the
memo on how to play the game and i did
not deposit
i did not deposit i have to deposit at
least something because this is
embarrassing
freaking idiot the game's half over and
i just figured out how to play
i gotta go back to free-for-all this is
not for me mommy is a care package so
get after it get after it where do i
stick
my clover
yep yep
yep you're dead you're dead you're dead
let's go please don't please don't
respond i gotta i gotta stick my clover
in the pot
this is easy i don't even wait for
anything i just like stick it in
now i'm freaking figuring it out and the
game's gonna be over
oh ears we both killed each other this
is fun
i'm enjoying it oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
how long is this game my god
st patrick's day is gonna be over
where's that pot
we lost i yelled a lot was it loud do
you think
it was pretty loud i was pretty loud
yeah i couldn't hear myself
no i didn't think you could did you say
anything to me
uh i tried uh well these sound
really incredible i'm actually quite
surprised and also they're very
comfortable
super comfy super cushiony a perfect fit
i like that it has the big bold
lettering
in the inner ear cups here and here's
the microphone so you can see there's
like a little light like look at this
you can turn it on and you can turn it
off so you'll easily be able to see kind
of like out of your
your peripheral vision if it's on or off
and i like that these dials
are very easy to turn one is for volume
and one is for a mix between the volume
and chat so if you are
hanging out chatting with some people
you'll be able to adjust that volume
very easily
you've got your power button here you've
got these soft cushiony little ear cups
and also this is really soft too the top
little headband and it just looks cool
i just want to give you guys a quick
look at the new xbox headset i'm super
excited about this
i would love to hear from you guys did
you order them are you gonna get them
if not which headsets are you guys
currently using for your gaming setup
would love to read those in the comments
below see you in the next video
give me a test
hello
today or unboxing something
that you can see on the front here uh
all right
let's just i'll just take another sip
okay
ah i uh this is my full-time job
[Music]